hallo liebe leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück weil kari antwortet
dieser
und zwar aus berlin aus unserem studio
wieder ja und wir legen gleich los mit
euren freunden einige vorher noch kurz
wir haben ja nicht gerade gebeten hier
ein bisschen studios etappen aufzubauen
weil wir dachten das sind deco sieht
immer schöner aus als ein lehrer tischen
wenn ich kurz vorstellen was wir haben
im 2 ohne kaffee er selber trinkt kaffee
wir kriegen eine uhr um euch zu zeigen
dass wir auch noch später rahmen
arbeiten dass hier was ist ja ich weiß
kuranyi
das ist nur ohne und da wollen wir
setzen auf das vor dem greenscreen
funktioniert wenn ihr seht ihr jetzt was
oder ihr seht ein loch man weiß es nicht
denn anni oder ihr sehen hintergrund
also es ist ein kohlrabi haben wir hier
sein iphone heute er gerne präsentieren
wenn wir keine werbung ein leeres glas
ein paar ordner eine eine enge kiste
usb-sticks und hörer also nur damit ihr
wisst das stell die amish sich unter
einer guten studio deko vor und auch
vokabeln natürlich damit wir auch ein
paar vokabeln euch bei ring und dann
noch diesen schönen ring den wir
geschenkt bekommen ok wollen wir
anfangen mit freier 1 wir haben heute
fragen mitgebracht von dana und
adventure und von easy german also wir
fragen heute verschiedene fragen
ich fange an mit denn pizarro
denn hat uns geschrieben harry great job
danke ich mag sehr was du machst die
videos von easyjet haben mir sehr
geholfen mein deutsch zu verbessern
leider kann ich das nicht wie die
deutschen aussprechen wäre das ein
problem und noch etwas ok erstmal zu der
ersten frage denn wir haben das gerade
schon existiert mit dem mehrere
das ist natürlich nicht so einfach in
deutsch es gibt drei erst in deutschland
das eine ehre
fangen wir an mit dem einfachsten dass
er am ende eines wortes das ist nämlich
ein man kann es eigentlich ersetzen mit
einem a zum beispiel mutter also es ist
nicht mutter sagen würde amerika die
us-mutter genau mutter linda mutter aber
aber alle amerikaner amerikaner aaron
ich bin amerikanerin dara amerikanerin
wenn das ersatz im wort drinsteht dann
wird in der regel hier hinten gesprochen
das ist ähnlich wie das ch das ist ja
auch schwierig für viele andere in
ansprachen wird hier gar nichts gebildet
oder und rollen lehrer amerikanerin ich
habe stünden laden für den schwieger
gesessen und probiert es zu machen
es ist immer schwer diese wird probiert
also es kommt immer immer immer immer
immer immer es kommt immer wie vorne
weißt du was wenn du den mund so hast du
machst das quasi amerikaner und ich
mache das hier amerikaner ja du spürst
dass auch hier wenn du redest
er kenne ja sehr gut amerikaner
amerikaner ja jetzt muss es nur noch
flüssig januar ist gerade eingefallen
dass er dazu auch noch eine übung hat
und jährlich kommt jetzt mal vor die
kamera und zeigt euch das wie man das
wäre also das wichtigste ist also eine
gute eine gute übung achtung ihr braucht
ein bisschen wasser und dann gibt es ein
besseres morgen da ist auch schon dass
er in gurken in seiner bürger gurgeln
und jetzt liebe leute nur das dritte er
aber das dritte er ist nicht so wichtig
möchte ich sagen denn es wird eigentlich
nur in bayern gesprochen
es ist dass man nennt das auch das
spanische er dadurch etwas machen es
wird ein mir ist hier vorne gebildet
also wie ich der unterschied das andere
was man ihn überall anders spricht es
wird hier hier gebildet wie man gurgeln
und 1 man benutzt das auch anstatt der
amerikaner ist amerika
ich kann das gar nicht sagen aber ich
habe mein tipp für euch und zwar in
unserem video easy german nummer 131 aus
namibia
erinnert euch da gab es eine frau
berichten breiter eine lehrerin aus
deutschland die dort unterrichtet hat
und sie hat sich selber vorgestellt und
das könnt ihr euch nochmal anhören wenn
dir das hört bei minute 340 wird stellt
sich selber vor und vielleicht hört in
diesen kleinen nur um sich spricht ihre
rr in ihrem eigenen namen etwas anders
aus als ich das gemacht habe grade
seminare und rollcom sc mein name ist
playstation kletter und ich kam erst
deutschland sperrten breiter
gar nicht sprechen also das könnte
tatsächlich leute in bayern sprechen
echte zweite frage von denn du hast noch
eine zweite frage stellt ist noch etwas
ich kann noch nicht verstehen den
unterschied zwischen hin und her zum
beispiel hinaus heraus könnte es in
einer episode erklären
vielen dank viele grüße aus rumänien
liebe grüße an dich nach rumänien
denn carsten thamm erklärung da hin und
her ja her ist wenn etwas herab herr ist
wenn etwas zu dir kommen solltest
claudia und hin ist wenn es weg gehen
soll sondern als dies tatsächlich eine
perspektive weil es bedeutet genau das
gleiche
aber wenn ich quasi sagen will dass
etwas zu mir kommen soll janosch komm
doch mal her kurz kommt schon dann hallo
ich sage ja nicht kannst du mal kurz
herkommen aber
daher hab ich so eine übung für so viele
übungen erläutert was wir alles zu hause
nachmachen können könnt ihr auch kurabi
noch dazu da was ja heute von 19 jahre
hause noch eine frage ist das erlaubt
mit er hier oder leer
eigentlich ist es ja es ist leer aber
mehr habe ich von meinem mann nicht
bekommen
er ist gerade kaffee trinken wird er
hinter der kamera holt er sich im café
sitzen hier ist bayern anderes als den
rest von deutschland dass leute die
gespräche also eher deutsch marokkaner
amerika also ich weiß nicht wovon sie
waren also aber sollte haben gefragt ist
weil etwas anderes oder ist das nur
etwas was die leute sagen weil oft
bekomme ich kommentare von deutsche bahn
ist nicht deutschland
also das ist wichtig wer stellt die
frage weil es gibt es ein bisschen so
eine engine als er selber eine spannung
zwischen bayern und im rest von
deutschland bayern nennt sich auch der
freistaat
und manchmal hat man das aber haben die
anderen deutschen das gefühl bayern wäre
auch gerne ein eigener staat
und es gibt super sachen diesen an
ich würde aber gerne schon sagen viele
sachen sind ähnlichen aber es gibt einen
dialekt dass ich einmal so leute reden
ein bisschen anders gut aber in anderen
regionen gibt es auch dialekte es gibt
halt noch ein bisschen mehr tradition
es war lucia spiel es gibt mehr
traditionelle kleidung denn wir haben
uns ja mal in münchen getroffen
du hast in den bergen solche kleinen
gibt's ryan ramsay getroffen ja da hast
du dir und solche kleidung gibt es in
bayern
und nirgendwo anders jetzt werde komme
ich bin ich also irgendwo anders sagen
welche es machen es gibt auch in keinen
anderen regionen irgendwie traditionelle
kleidung die leute noch tragen oder zum
spaß oder sowas wie oktoberfest gibt es
auch nicht gleichzeitig die anderen
deutschen in ganz deutschland die sind
aber so ein bisschen die finden das doof
dass sie immer alle leute denken ganz
deutschland ist wie bayern
weil das stereotyp von deutschland ist
oktoberfest großes bier
dirndl lederhose so dass es ja leisten
das ist brezeln weißwurst dass es so ein
bisschen das bild was man in deutschland
hat wenn du weißt ins deutsche aus
lederklamotten ja leicht rum und das ist
natürlich nicht ganz deutschland weil
ganz deutschland sieht eigentlich anders
aus als bayern
ja ja ja aber generell will ich sagen es
ist jetzt nicht so ein ganz großer
sie wählen auch ein bisschen anders
bayern-welt grundsätzlich konservativer
als die cdu die konservativere party die
christlich demokratische union die haben
in bayern eine eigene partei
ein bisschen eines vielleicht kann man
so sagen wie wie england und schottland
zone
okay vielleicht verbessern während sie
haben auch holland hat auch die wellen
ein bisschen anders
speziell aber trotzdem zu sein
mehr viel gemeinsam dritte frage kommt
heute von evgeny arens kaida vor
und sie schreibt uns halo kari kannst du
bitte der unterschied zwischen zwei
ähnlichen verben erklären
zwar nutzen und benutzen dann schon mal
gehört hab ich sie gehört aber das ist
es schwierig also ich habe darüber
nachgedacht es ist wirklich schwierig zu
erklären wann welche benutzt wird also
definitiv da benutzt ist richtig ja
tatsächlich ja es ist ein schwieriges
wort wir haben eben schon ein bisschen
recherchiert dazu wenn man das übersetzt
englisch dann wird für nutzen wir glaube
ich jude leistbar das war im internet
aber es stimmt nicht immer der nutzen
ist
und das manchmal ist das auch so aber es
gibt ganz feine unterschiede und manche
kann man beides benutzen manchmal nur
eins und das ist ganz oft auch ein
gefühl ich habe mal ein paar beispiele
aufgeschrieben und daran kann man
vielleicht so ein bisschen dieses gefühl
bekommen ich glaube nämlich dass das
nutzen es geht eher um abstrakte dinge
zum beispiel nutzt twitter oder kann ich
mal deinen deinen wlan nutzen also das
etwas was man nicht anfassen kann
aber wenn ich zum beispiel sagen kann
ich deinen kuranyi benutzen das würde
ich nicht sagen weil sind kann man ja
nicht benutzten entweder essig dem
besser weg
ein iphone benutzer kann ich mal kurz
zur iphone benutzer kann ich mal kurz
darf ich mal entschuldigung darf ich mal
kurz ihr handy benutzen ich möchte mir
niemand anrufen da willst du ihn
benutzen
etwas was man in der hand hatte oder
darf ich meinen rechner benutzten die
tasse hast du die chance die schon
benutzt zum ende haben wir noch eine
ganz kurze frage und zwar von on3 passt
der nicoise derneck war ich hoffe ich
habe das richtig ausgesprochen herr
lokale ich folge euch schon seit jahren
danke andré kannst du bitte hier
öffentlich fragen ob jemand auskennt
easy vlaams machen kann
egal ob es klappt oder nicht ich wollte
es einfach nur probieren dank nur an
drei sehr coole idee wie wäre es
natürlich wahnsinnig freuen also wenn da
jemand ist von euch aus flandern
vielleicht sogar auskennt
ich war meinen dieser von das schiff
stand hat ein sammler kurz gemacht sein
wird heißen zeiten überhaupt wir waren
mit leuten aus aller welt in gent kind
was doch mal in belgien eine der
schönsten städte europas wenn ihr eine
new road trip
jetzt muss ich gehe jetzt um den agenten
ist es wirklich eine wunderschöne stadt
und wenn du da draußen bist wunderbar
belgier oder wunderbare belgierinnen und
du siehst unser programm zufällig und du
hast lust auch mal ein video zu machen
so wie wir auf der straße fußball um
flemmig also niederländisch aber in
belgien zu zeigen und zu unterrichten
wir 25 freuen und wir wollen unbedingt
dass uns schreibst und andrea also für
uns und für andré schreib uns ja das war
schon für heute ja dann ist irgendwas
offengeblieben irgendeine frage
also was ich verstehe immer noch nicht
was macht man eigentlich klar dass auch
nicht benutze ich nie ich benutze ich
das nie schloss macht man damit aber
schmeckt firma dies oder das nicht
vergleichen mit ein anderer ist es wie
es sie ein bisschen aus wie eine zwiebel
man macht einfach die schale ok und dann
vielleicht wenn er es ist dann macht er
ein foto davon holte ein messer gibt es
in amerika nicht keine ahnung auch wenn
ja dann ich habe es nie gegessen
ich habe das definitiv nie gesehen kann
zufrieden oder es riecht noch nichts
sieht aus wie apfel könnte das riecht
schon wieder kartoffeln aus den apfel
respektieren das wie ist wie ein lieber
leute das war karin deine antwort sagen
als nächstes würden wir mal die man
anrufen vom handy
ja ja einfach es benützen
ich werde das mal benutzen und euch will
ich sagen seid uns mehr fragen also wenn
ihr fragen habt deutsche sprache
deutsche kultur ich weiß nicht alles
aber der versuch des mühlhäuser sendung
danke fürs zuschauen und schritt schickt
aufragen unbedingt zu uns bis bald